[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
hello everybody
and welcome to a unconventional
gamespot stream
it's unconventional fridays
unconventional fridays this ain't about
no preview this ain't about no hot game
that's coming out this is about
our boy michael hym because it's oh stay
here
oh
[ __ ] i just realized i'm looking at the
thing at the bottom and it looks like i
don't know like we like you died and
this is like a youtube [ __ ]
oh day
listen shout out to the god
oh [ __ ]
yeah uh it's probably not the last time
you'll probably see my dumbass on like
game spot stuff and probably giant boss
stuff in the future but yeah i am
officially dipping out as an employee of
uh red ventures gamespot
previously america's most watched
network cbs interactive oh we don't we
don't talk about them no more
dead to us
it's my last day i could talk i'm gonna
talk mad [ __ ] about no i'm just kidding
it's uh it's all it's all good here it's
all
fun vibes we're gonna be vibing today uh
some of y'all some of y'all know me
mostly i'll probably don't give [ __ ]
which is yeah to be honest it's fair
uh
to be fair if y'all have a problem with
this take it up with jan jan is the one
who gave us the keys and that is my that
is my brother from another mother oh if
you're on giant bomb specifically yeah
if you're watching this on japan oh yeah
that's right that's right um so i'm
speaking to the giant bomb audience you
know what i'm saying i was i was once
one of y'all watching from afar hoping
that one day i get to do something like
this
i did it and now i'm out
you said i did everything i need came
here to do [ __ ] y'all
yep
uh i'm just kidding i love you all
so
much
what are we doing what are we having fun
with today what are we doing here
so today
i don't know honestly i just thought of
like what can all what can four
uh
boys do together what do four boys do
together when they get together and when
they're gamers i can think of some
things
i could think of
some things too if you know what i'm
saying uh they get together they hook up
a bunch of xboxes and they play halo
multiplayer that's what they do um so
we're gonna play halo master chief
collection together so
if y'all don't know who we are
uh i'm michael i'm the one dipping out
uh matt espinelli is also my brother
from another mother uh it's been my
day one since
since coming to gamespot jean luke also
and ben who's been uh ben and i actually
started on the same day at gamespot and
yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah we did cause i remember watching i
remember seeing ben
sitting outside while i was sitting
outside waiting to go in the first day
and i was like oh he looks like a gamer
because he has a twitch bag
oh you know it
that's all the gamer gamer energy right
there yeah so ben has been a major
influence and all four of us um
like to commit crimes so
that's how we bonded as a group of
friends at gamespot
so but yeah also
matt espinelli my boy
this is also partially for you as well
right
i guess so yeah um
from being honest yeah i'm also
my last day of game spot is coming up
too on august 31st
if y'all don't know who i am that's
totally understandable don't appear on
screens or anything but uh i am
gamespot's features and guides person so
i manage a lot of that kind of stuff on
the site so if you were ever helped by a
cool guide on gamespot
i was likely the one who either wrote it
or totally made it happen
yeah so yeah yeah um
yeah we're we're dipping out so yeah
we're like [ __ ] y'all but uh we're gonna
have fun first so uh let's get let's get
some headshots yeah
what i'm saying i hope we match it
yeah let's attempt to get some head
shots so all four of us are playing
uh but you only see jean-luc and my feed
matt and ben are professionals you don't
need to see how good they are uh at this
but uh
if you want to pay attention to how
[ __ ] whack i am
at this game you watch the right the
feet on the right john luke who's a real
gamer who's a split gate pro he's on the
left i ain't playing with a controller
though so when you're playing mouse
keyboard so you know
that's how you're supposed to play pro
game [ __ ]
yeah see i'm playing with keyboard and
mouse so i have no excuses if i'm bottom
fragging but i'm probably going to be
bottom first okay
so
do you guys have a halo game preference
and or mode preference for what we're
we're making it into
probably just like slayer snipers
basic [ __ ]
anything but for right
say what right
anything before
anything before sure
yeah
okay no i don't play
on halo 4 i don't
i like three and two and one and reach
much more than all right well we'll
start with everything before
player we'll go from there
okay cool
excellent soundtrack though
and for i'll say that oh this is uh some
of you guys are idling i think you just
gotta like oh what you just gotta like
move your thing around it's me moving
around uh
for everyone who's joining us thank you
so much for being here
um
it's your first time realizing who we
are peace
uh but yeah this is gonna be fun so i
thank you all for uh for chilling here
yeah uh and vibing with us
uh yeah
tony the swordsman the twitch chat says
where the wholesome hentai at uh oh come
on it's a constant never-ending journey
that's uh
these are not the channels so i can
switch i can switch my feet uh we can
show you all what's good
also
oh my sensitivity is very low
there's gonna be a whole bunch of oh my
controls are not the right oh yeah it's
like which controls
it's really dark oh my gosh what is this
two we're playing two airplane two yeah
it's a two one um this is an
it's about quicker anniversary creek
which one
which one it's called rattle creek
originally right right
oh [ __ ] okay i'm gonna get my ass
already
oh this fool's got a
[ __ ] uh battle rifle
no there's i don't think there's bots in
this game getting handed by bots
i don't think so unless they added that
which would be wild
i'll say because their their names are
looking a little suspect
that's because everybody's
papa bear 907.
that's some real default ass gamer tags
right here
um if you have if you have four or more
numbers in your name
i feel like you're a bot
that's fair you know what
i went into that
seat
hey bands these booze at what
oh [ __ ]
how y'all doing
up there is that you mad
dude that's me
clay packs for for you asking why uh my
frame rate is better than michael's that
is because um
i am playing the game like directly off
of my capture card like into my computer
because i'm the one who's streaming out
um michael is like sending his feed to
me yeah then so like it's not gonna look
as clean
i am getting 60 frames per second uh oh
also shots at the to playpacks hey
that's uh vinco giant bomb free company
on trial final fantasy 14 gang gang oh
yeah
uh thank you for coming through
you'd love to see it
yeah i got i got a dukey frame rate but
i'm getting i'm getting 60 personally
uh that's just personally i'm getting 60
frames per second right right yo we are
getting our ass
i'm playing like garbage
oh my god i forgot to mention this is
the first time i played halo in the last
like three years
yeah maybe we needed to warm up with
some like
oops
how do we switch greens
oh god
third time's the charm you know you
gotta you gotta work up to it yeah
yeah
pull up to uh somebody else's streaming
platform we play like ass
we even play video games
now
it's very true
according to the
all the comment sections we don't so
and i'm not disproving them right now
oh my god
[Laughter]
bro
oh my god i'm being the one the thing is
listen
listen they know all the nade spots
they're hacking
there it is that's that's the one
look at that
they're hacking bro
i don't know how else to put it
there's no other explanation for this
oh look at these hackers bro they
spawned like
they made me spawn in front of them
[Laughter]
did we make a mistake
no maybe
just like all my favorite games and then
we end up playing halo
uh i got one i'm alive again see they're
they're hacking bro
they got wall hacks
let's see
dude we're getting we're getting
probably
getting punk dude
chelsea's in the twitch
oh chelsea
see he killed me with like two shots
from the battle rifle that's how you
know he's hacking
really just
that good
i dare you to shoot i dare you to shoot
me oh he shot me
i was like he's too close
oh no
game over yes please just
oh it just ended that was embarrassing
oh
okay
okay okay i need a little bit
i'm loose i'm limber
i need to get my it's [ __ ] gamer a
little more than that
all right listen there's only we can
only go up from here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is all part of the area
yeah look at this y'all two and fourteen
oh
my god
don't don't look at it let's not play
with these guys we could probably back
out so like yeah
his name is literally on fire
yeah we don't need that yeah let's um
yeah we're just warming up yeah let's
try again yeah yeah
oh boy i don't have the i'm gonna pull
up the giant bomb chat at least since
because i'm a premium member you know
what i'm saying
lifetime
oh how you do fellow premium members
okay it's halo 3.
i'm not familiar oh this is one of the
maps they added in um
they've been adding maps from like that
free to play halo like russian game it's
just gonna say i don't know what this
map is it's weird i don't i don't i
don't i don't i don't dig that's the
thing
yeah there was like a it was like halo
online i think it was called and um
i'm not
i'm not the biggest fan that they added
them in into this game because i don't
think they're very good
i'm about to find out it's unfortunate i
think i've i don't think i've played
these i probably played these
maps
before i don't know we'll see
we got an assault rifle start though
that's exciting oh i play oh this map is
sick there's like a really easy way to
cheese sniping [ __ ]
yo whoops
why am i controlling
i was toning bad noobs it was wild ben
you should definitely go and set um
like your control scheme to be like yeah
universal and like apply to all games
that just not stick
no i guess not okay okay
come on i know you're here where are you
yeah
he's who's that
i'm just gonna go through all of them
i'm gonna check my obs to make sure i'm
not dry uh
yeah i'm not dropping frames yeah
or they're actually oh [ __ ]
yeah it's sending well i'm sending you
i'm sending it out to you at 30. at 30.
that's probably why you could um that
would go ahead and redo it
oh [ __ ] my bad
all good
it's fun to make sure the viewers have
an optimal experience
[ __ ] your work
yeah halo 3 i'm doing a little better at
least
y'all don't have to carry me
listen it's been a while since uh
it's been a while
since i played halo
all right i got the shotgun we're good
oh nice
nice shotgun right there we go
yeah man uh shotgun shotgun's the
tickets actually i feel like we should
all be like
squad
a tight tight squad
fun hello
i remember uh squad that's the game that
rory played on yeah years ago
they just kept saying squad
squad
oh i like the silence smg is this like
yeah i think is it is it ass or is it
hey it's not bad it's not bad that's a
that's a pretty solid addition that they
added
i shouldn't be zooming in
that one yeah
[Music]
okay we're keeping up we're keeping up
yeah it feels good okay
yeah you just gotta get that one warm up
you know
i like 12 year olds playing halo for the
first time because it's on game pass
my god
this is why you're leaving
randy said
man you can't play hill anymore what are
you doing here
wait what randy's watching
in approximately an hour and uh 15
minutes i will no longer have access to
slack
so
or my email so if i forgot to do
anything
[ __ ] y'all
you'll be free let me know if you need a
the link to your to your own
oh that's right i i probably do all
right i'll i'll give it to you later on
yes it already starts
uh what after after my should get revolt
i need to focus i'm trying to focus
we're here for video games
this guy with the sniper rifle is good
yeah he's pretty he's pretty alright
god damn it
i'm mad at him now oh come on come on
yo they they pulled way ahead we were up
10 9 now it's 22 11. there we go okay
okay
oh man i'm sorry i'm sorry that folks
have to watch this
shameful
you know do it dog that next week
there's going to be a youtube thumbnail
that's going to be like
games media game spot can't even play
halo
what's wrong with games journalism
nowadays
just go watch my split gate video i do
some dope [ __ ] it's true that's flicking
video is very good
did i finally watch that the other night
and yes that is very like okay good job
buddy thank you it's a lot of
the fun genre
and editing oh [ __ ]
these [ __ ] got rocket launchers
oh no
yeah there we go
oh [ __ ] the pistols trash in this game
oh yeah pistol
garbage
the garbage um we're down nine we can
come we can come back we do it we can
still still make it work yeah
i need to get a sniper rifle
yo what's up once i got the sniper rifle
it's over for you hoes
there it is
oh [ __ ]
i guess
all right
got healing over here if you needed to
oh thank you
yeah
thanks phil
got to do it any time
yeah [ __ ]
see the way my mouse is set up it's like
uh
um
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the sensitivity
the buttons
yeah yeah you know it's a dpi
the dpi is uh
yeah there you go
yeah no scopes oops
god damn it man all right oh [ __ ] i have
a pistol it's over i'm dying i'm gonna
die
all right that was the end of michael
i'm behind you i got your back r.i.p
pepperonis
i saw clay packs talking about final
fantasy xiv
don't say that around me don't say the
magic word
oh [ __ ] look out
oh [ __ ]
oh shoot
what he needs
come on
okay i i met you in the middle of the
ring around the rosie it was real
intense for a bit it was yeah you got
rockets up there
yo they got rockets up there
oh i feel like we can come back we're
only oh [ __ ] on my back
we're only down six
five minutes for me
one more burst there it is
all right okay okay okay i have 11 kills
but i also probably have like 20 deaths
i'm all about inefficiency
if you like that
[ __ ]
shiitake mushrooms
i've heard that a while ago
oh damn it oh [ __ ] i think
um after this match i need to uh
like reset if i go afk
[ __ ]
uh you
gotta take care of some [ __ ] man do it
uh hold on i'll mute myself
all right let me switch over to my my
full screen
okay
how are we doing over here
oh
dude phil was fighting philly oh my god
that's true uh we know who you're
fighting your evil clone
it's like how solid had to fight liquid
man
sorry i'll be back in a minute actually
i'm gonna oh hold on i'm gonna try and
die as fast as i can so end the match
actually the message match is gonna i'll
be back yeah you're good sorry i don't
know you're fine oh you're you're a-okay
you don't need them
you do it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh
i said yeah progression
the first one very rough the second one
starting to get kind of a footing back
third one that's when everything just
starts
rolling together
that's when we win it's the third time's
the charm thing
yeah that's it's a total saying it holds
truth uh on all levels to anything that
you ever do in your life
um for the most part
there's a real theory to it oh my god i
think i just try to do a
grenade i didn't get fragged
oh no
we did the trade at the end you know
what
that's not as bad that's not as
embarrassing as our previous one so
yeah
i'll take it i got more than zero kills
let's uh let's wait a minute see if
michael michael comes back um
yeah
and do his business
how's the old chat doing tonight we're
here at celebrate michael hym who's not
here at the moment taking a very
important call
like you said we're also here to
celebrate you matt is you're you're yeah
yeah yeah i suppose that's uh that is
the case
before it pulls us back in
oh yeah let me do that
uh
yeah is there is there anything that
you're you're particularly really proud
of matt that you've done in your time
here
like everything obviously you're you're
very proud of the
work that you do but is there one thing
where you're like i put a lot of work
into this and i feel like
this is it this is the thing
i think a couple things that kind of
come to mind are
i just remember like my resident evil 3
remake preview coverage like a while
back that's just right like a really
passionate uh preview about that game
which i still i enjoy the game today
people say a lot about resident evil 3
remake but i generally like that game in
the preview phase and i genuinely like
that game after it came out uh
but i was happy about that just because
we got to do a video
version and thing of it and oh yeah it's
a chance for me to just like lean in and
go ham hi you know this is me matt i
like games i like resident evil so
um that's something i was proud of
yeah
well thank you yeah
uh something that i was reminded of that
i thought was like
super cool and kind of relevant uh to
this week
release and game release is you got to
be the uh english dub over
yeah [ __ ] cool dude
oh yeah that's right
um yeah that was a really random
opportunity oh thank you um
yeah it was a random opportunity that
came up for all for anyone who hasn't
checked that out that's like an episode
of audio logs which is a show that
gamespot used to do we just had
developers just kind of wax on about
something they their career and things
that they're working on
so for 51 since i was like i think was
that like one of our first like japanese
like
language ones
maybe
yeah
uh but anyway that was like an
opportunity where like
uh lucy who
mostly runs the show um
asked me to do
the the dub for pseudo51 just based on
like what the translator had given us
and so yeah just kind of went for it um
big fantasy if just like 751's like work
throughout the year is all kind of up
and down but i'm more on the upside
these days because no one here was three
um yeah yeah that was a really cool
opportunity
um
evan
i like doing vo posted it in the in the
youtube chat um
oh excuse me
i think that's what he posted i don't
know i didn't click on it but uh
you have to forgive me they found where
i am
oh my god
ben get out of there now
bmw
are we going back to the studio someday
who knows
what question
maybe hopefully
look who we got here
she's back all right let's get it
i can't wait for y'all to get in trouble
on monday
yeah why why why would that happen
because we've about to turn up hey
hey
come on shout out to my dominicans
you know what i'm saying
we have definitely
we have drinking on many of streams
i keep thinking about the grand blue
the grand blue one which is oh that was
a ton of fun we were turned up on the
grand blue because the grand blue
when we did the what was it the beta
yeah yeah uh because the bait didn't go
live until six
at night
thursday or friday so yeah
oh we still want to do this like yeah so
like [ __ ] it turn up
so i'm about to go wake her wasted too
you know what i'm saying
he's in the building
so i live with blessing junior from um
kind of funny that's my boy
uh and we had a truly phase and our
recycling looked like a
sorority house because it was just two
reasons
um
it's the good stuff though that the
truly lemonade is like probably the best
hey carbon in the youtube chat saying hi
hey
hello oh hey carbon
shouts out to you
um joey is in the youtube
oh my god joey is just like the most
loveliest man i can't believe he's real
like i'm such a big fan of joey like
he's just
he's damn he's a good one he's one of
the good ones
i love that guy
oh
all right uh still time yup
this one's for clay packs
uh all right uh
matt you just gotta
wiggle that controller
oh i'll get wiggled there we go let's go
yeah
we need to be gaming people have tuned
in for some gaming
it's true some serious gaming here
yep the gaming doesn't stop
oh my god there's a lot of final fantasy
14 chat going on in the giant bomb chat
i'd love to see that of course let me
let me address the the crowd here i i
hear the crowd clamoring
um listen there's a free trial
level 60 heaven's word
no restrictions on play time
let's get it
um so
uh ducktales says this is your stream do
what you want hey
thank you it's true it's sometimes you
know the funny [ __ ] is like i've been at
gamespot for five years and i still feel
like
i'm on training wheel like i'm like
sitting at the kid's table for some
reason i don't know like i don't know i
don't know if it's imposter syndrome i i
don't
maybe it's it's part partly that
but i still feel like
everything i do
i need to like ask for approval or i'm
like ah [ __ ] you know well i mean you
still should be like
advice and feedback on things we always
do that like that's part of the dna of
working in media but
he was like shy to share ideas like uh
no one really wants to read that no one
wants to watch that yeah
dude everyone wants to hear me talk
about final fantasy 14 well guess what
it's my [ __ ] career now
i'm sure
oh
maybe i'll make a video about this i
don't know i don't know
maybe my split footage is
i wish we were watching ben stream ben's
i got a sick like jumping no scope head
shot just now but you don't want to be
watching
[Laughter]
see if folks don't know uh i'm i'm gonna
be uh working at uh fanboy.com starting
next week
yeah [ __ ] yeah
specifically
as the section lead for
covering final fantasy 14
matt's really mad about that who is true
yeah i'm not happy about this dude come
on
i don't i don't well no you you're gonna
you're gonna be killing it in your own
right
man
i'm excited for you
your own yes i appreciate that
appreciate that i and i am excited for
you as well it's quite the level up
this job that you've taken i'm just
trying to find a way to do the final
fantasy jingle but i feel like we'll be
too cheesy and on the nose
it's never stopped me from doing
anything wacky
at our at our job
dog
oh [ __ ]
at uh when matt announced his uh
departure
this [ __ ] danced during a
company-wide meeting on camera
and cosplayed as majima
i put it together
it was like oh like a 30 second like hey
what's up y'all i'm i'm dripping out
this whole came through in full
cosplay
and i'll respect that
just playing some of that friday night
because it was friday you know it was
friday
it's time to celebrate friends
i think the thing i'm gonna miss about
matt is uh
his his excellent like obscure
japanese funk bands that he always plays
at the beginning and uh
every meeting
yeah oh yeah i'm gonna miss that uh do
you have a spot you have it's like a
spotify playlist map that you want to
share with me
honestly yes
that is i got a couple playlists yeah
that has gotten to me like a big box
many japanese bands um
we're non-japanese fans well i've been
absolutely obsessed with ginger root uh
thanks to matt yeah ginger root
it's a fantastic
band
if joey's here he can vouch for ginger
root
uh some asian american talent y'all in
the chat check out the band called
ginger root they're really funky
and they're quirky
they just put out a new lp real good
that's right the city slicker
ep rather
specifically check out the song loretta
oh [ __ ] you got snuck out
okay
i want everyone in the chat to
check out about tokonoma
p-e-o-c-o-n-o-n-o-m-a
uh matt showed me that band and my life
have hasn't been the same since
it's the perfect it's a perfect work
music to be honest
it's like it's all instrumental there's
no singer there's no lyrics but i just
feel a lot of emotions when i listen to
token
it's
communication through pure sound
having somebody that we
really recommend
music to you is is invaluable because i
am i don't actively listen to music all
that much i'm just not that kind of
person but like and i also don't seek it
out so like i need like people to like
recommend me stuff like all the time
yeah yeah so it's like
i
i value that part of our friendship matt
you can
recommend me oh great
oh [ __ ] my bad oh yeah joey joey in the
chat saying ginger root goat
ellie yeah yeah it is also a filipino a
filipino band called uh that uh alyssa
put me on
um called up up dharma
they're very good ah
i think sometimes they sing in tagalog
uh sometimes they sing in english oh
that's cool
yeah i'd say they're great
yeah they're very um
chill kind of experimental rock
hmm
let's check that out
yeah i think you i think
it's uh it's up your alley it aligns
with other things that you've
recommended to me
but i'll say sick
okay all right all right
mental note taken
so i don't want to say that the third
time's charm rule is
coming through but it's really working
out yeah
that's why you're you're doing yeah
you're supposed to do it yeah you're
multitasking you guys got a lot of
things
for the oh my god
oh [ __ ] sniper rifle it's over for me oh
no it's not um
[Laughter]
how do they have two energy swords it's
not even energy sword sunday
it's true
halo infinite absolutely needs to have a
gameplay mode called energy sword sun
only happens
it's a it's a rotating place you know
what i'm saying yeah they absolutely
need to do that here
dude
like legitimately like halo 2 uh one of
the favorite modes i would use to do
like with my friends is we'd all get
together and we would do like split
screen uh energy swords only because in
halo 2 all the energy sorts of infinite
ammo and you would just be like all
right first a 50 with energy swords
because it felt like it felt more fair
because it's like
dude my friends were so [ __ ] good at
halo and like you give them like a
sniper and they like whip my ass but
it's like energy sword anyone's game
sure what's going on
i'm saying
the deflects and everything that you
could do
yeah
oh what is the sekiro
yeah perry
anyway i'm still awful with the sniper
rifle so that's good
oh i'm trying i'm trying to keep the
chat i've never seen the [ __ ]
yeah i got this oh this is invisible
whoa
somehow
with that around you
we're okay
that's not the first time ben is safe oh
god
[Laughter]
yeah i've talked about this on multiple
episodes of game spot after dark a fine
podcast um
that i've quit competitive games
mostly because i just
even when i do well even when we win i
just get like mad frustrated
like everything for like i don't know
what it is
as i've gotten older i've gotten
grumpier
oh like people are legit like good at
this game and it pisses me off
uh the reflexes aren't what they used to
be yeah
um
but i think playing with with friends is
uh staves off a bit of that frustration
because like if we if we lose you know
i'll
i'll lose with my boys that's that's
cool that's fine uh i will say
oh sorry then you go first oh i just say
i'm the same way i i hardly play
competitive stuff by myself i only
played stuff with friends now
i i will say if you want to feel good
about yourself play some split gate
right now like because the something
about
the yeah played on pc because about the
current like pool of of players like
i absolutely destroy everybody every
time it also apparently feels so good
i don't know if that's true
what do you say oh does it pull in but
apparently yeah apparently split pulls
in a lot of bots currently oh i didn't
realize that yeah i'd explain it then
this is good for capture purposes
yeah yeah
[Music]
you know i was like dang we got this
wrapped up and then i started really
botching it oh no yo we're down by we're
down by one dude
[Laughter]
immediately somebody gets sniped
it just slowly started to fall apart
after that
it's okay
i we won that night guys
yeah you know we came so close that was
a victory that's like one of the that's
like the end of like a really good
sports movie you know like we're not
supposed to win but like you saw us get
there and we almost got there and it was
a win emotion the [ __ ] is this ted lasso
i don't know how to read i haven't
watched that lasso either but i heard
it's hurt it's really good i'm pretty
good lucy lucy james
seems to love it a lot
and
seal of approval
carry some weight we'll say
that's true
damn joey brought up our old uh deal for
dealer no deal stream we did oh my god
you guys remember that
was so
yeah for context joey like
what was it like amazon was selling like
ds copies a deal or no deal for like a
dollar
each so joey bought like 30 copies or
something like that and i'm like what do
you want to do with all those copies and
he's like we should like give him away
i'm like let's do like a
deal or no deal stream and we like put
like other things in the codes or
something
so it's like you gotta copy a dealer no
deal and you got
some fortnite socks or like whatever the
[ __ ] it was like
you get v books you get some v bugs
oh my god oh
joey i miss you so much
dog this this fool had like a stack of
30 copies of the illuminati on his desk
i was like i could only handle so much
howie mandel
like do something with this [ __ ]
i love that just waiting at that
teleporter
also uh when i have a good opportunity
uh matt padgett in the in the youtube
chat is spitting some um
some praise for both
uh both of you so i'll have to read that
in a sec oh
matt my god
matt padgett is like the most well he's
first off he's canadian
um second off he is the most
like even when he's being really polite
he's being rude and he's being rude he's
still being polite
maybe that's just canadian thing i don't
know how many candidates you got in the
chat throw up your maple leaves
canadians are
in my experience not just with matt
paget but with all canadians i know they
are simultaneously like they're
extremely polite and they're incredibly
raunchy
oh yeah they they they they the og susio
gang out there like
they they love they love a good like
real skirt in the line raunchy ass joke
damn i feel i feel pretty good about
this round
wait thank you which halo is this right
now this is a reach
this is okay i personally think reach is
the reach is my favorite multiplayer i
would agree
i also agree
well i like to a lot
i like like a like original two a lot
because it's a bit faster yeah two's got
that speed that i know i
don't really like
yeah
um how's the pistol in this one
it's better than three that's for sure
is the pistol only good in one
yeah like it's like well because in like
one it was like broken and then it's
like yeah it's basically a sniper riff
yeah and then and uh
two it's pretty bad three it's not great
and then i would say like from reach on
it's like
probably what it should be
i think it's the the game is where you
could do wield them you have to do some
weird balancing stuff with it
yeah that's the thing is like two and
three like you could do wheel dumb and
like
oh [ __ ] this was sprinting
uh i do remember the the reach beta
pistol being very good
oh yeah yeah i
kind of recall that as well like they
nerfed it
we talking canadians here yeah we are
do bottom of the canadian tier uh do
people from the [ __ ] uh quarterback
oh well you can say that
i can say that because uh
luke is french canadian no no no i'm not
actually i'm not actually
you're well my girlfriend's my
girlfriend's french canadian but i'm i'm
from vermont and uh which is on the
border of canada and like specifically
it's like two hours from like montreal
so we would get a lot of like
um
french canadian like people from like
quebec like would come like uh on
vacation to visit and they were always
like the biggest [ __ ] uh to like um
retailers in vermont like they were just
such dicks
i don't know
something about them
i'm calling them out
just someone's got it
someone's gotta put them in their place
and it's it's about time y'all luke and
i'm glad that you're here to do it
all you have french canadians
downstairs
oh no he ducked me and then he t-bagged
me a whole bunch oh you got tea bag
it was
i'm surprised it took this long cycle of
life
son of odd
[Laughter]
if i betrayed you with my slanderous
canadian talk
ah
i think john luke's the only one who's
had uh explicit experience with uh
french canadians
what the
dude i saw you get i saw ben i saw you
got stealth killed and i tried to do
something about it
things are disoriented this is so bad
this is so bagged
so good
uh gaming is a struggle man this is why
i don't stream like you don't you don't
want to watch this [ __ ]
this is why i don't care and
that's why i play visual novels
yeah hell yeah you can't lose a visual
novel well actually
maybe look you can make you make friends
not great at reading
yeah that's how you
have a game over and usual novel
i haven't been using my sprint okay
varchan does agree with me though he
says he's right uh quebec and she go to
vermont usually do suck
the both of them so i'm vindicated
every time i play halo it seems like the
other team is like so well coordinated
like as soon as you see one person come
in there's one person right behind them
to pick up a snack
it's it's wild just like
this
we're like a full party you think we
would be more coordinated
we're like half focusing we're talking
people in this chat you know
the good stuff oh okay yeah and i've
also got
a grapefruit as well
after that
let's not talk about numbers or scores
that's right varchain you are allowed to
say that this one doesn't count
i would like the chat to guess my next
kill death ratio for the next match
on point two somebody could do that
don't don't make them do that
going here in the look
chat uh
legendary wrong
okay well we're loading the next game uh
so from matt paget he was saying
uh michael business trips with you were
always the best i'll never forget them
and you know the reasons why
you know what you did
reasons that we can't talk about
there are things i think my favorite
this is like not specific at all it's
just
we were going through a parking lot to
like
an appointment or something and we were
visualizing we were all very hungover
and matt was just non-stop stream of
just
talking and you were like you just had
this look on your face like matt
shut up
it was so funny
that was just not just said [ __ ] oh
because we got we got dropped off behind
the the vegas convention center and
we're all like the other side yeah like
[ __ ] we need to walk around and then i
was already i was like not having
it because the driver [ __ ] dropped us
off in the wrong spot right and then
matt was just like
man i remember a couple years ago this
one
right whoa wait
all right relax my guy
also
he said uh he said matt you are an
unbelievable cheerleader you always made
me feel like the best person in the game
spot and i'm sure the feeling is mutual
among the rest of the staff seriously
you are the best
big facts what
oh no
well this team is really good but thank
you
if they don't have 117
[Music]
this is inspiring feelings in me where i
must dm matt padgett about how much
he's a cool dude and i love him and
thank you
seriously
i remember being like hungover
like the double tree marriott or some
[ __ ] we're waiting for an appointment or
no we're having lunch
yes we're having lunch the day we were
like hung over as [ __ ] yeah
we were doing mad coke at the ces party
no we weren't i'm
you need to get jeff baklar on here
right now
oops cause yeah he would have been up
for that right
yeah he was he was
that was the only time i i i ever have
gone to ces and like the so cnet always
throws this like big party and now he's
getting like a
pretty pretty big act i would say every
time um
yeah i was gonna say the one i went to
with you guys was janelle monae and i
feel like i lucked out and got the best
one because like hearing some of the
other ones i was like
i don't know about that but like dude
gentleman a was [ __ ] emotional
amazing easy what a choice man now she
is a performer yeah
seriously
always remember i think what is it
i think i saw one of those like uh talk
show live performances of her which was
doing tightrope holy crap i just that
was really hard to begin with yeah just
like seeing that live performance i was
like wow well that's the thing it's like
you're watching and you're like you did
not need to go this hard for for a
ces party for cnet right you did not do
that
it was amazing it was so good dude
that's sick
ah
what's inspiring so bad for anyone who
looked out and saw the macklemore one
oh yeah that was tight no it wasn't yeah
that's fine it was fine like i i okay
i do not [ __ ] with nakamura at all but
like
he gave a performance like he did his
thing and you gotta respect that sure
sure
i don't
i was like you know i wasn't vibing with
it but i was like if you vibe with this
this is good i think like jeff keeley
was there and like
i can't tell jeff kelly's vibe
and
nakamura i don't know i think they're
like long lost brothers
be honest
um uh
the hot goss on jeff baklar um let's see
uh oh yo i loved it so much and i think
i think it was 2019 or maybe it was when
we were uh when john luke you were there
but like matt padgett and jeff bakalar
talked about hockey
yes yeah that was the one i was at okay
that was yeah
i was like i can't wait i just want to
sit here and listen to jeff and matt
talk about it because a canadian
and obviously
like come on kill joy
some real hoodlum [ __ ] right there
um
man i i'm gonna i miss ces because
like we got to uh
was it 2019 i think
um yeah yeah 2019 school we got to go oh
no no it was uh 20 20 20 2020 was the
one we went to 2019 i went with lucy and
uh peter brown yeah and we did the we
did the cnets uh show stage with jeff
that was oh that was oh that was so much
fun
i got to be on cnn i could say that i
was on cnet
i know
you seen it
game over you [ __ ] noobs
50 to 18.
oh we are really we're in a world of
hurt don't don't look at it don't talk
again i'll drink tonight
i can do this all night y'all should we
uh should we get a different
should we just keep getting different
people every time well this is what we
do we eliminate a game anytime we have
like a horrible like score in it right
now i'm just saying halo 3 seems to be
our game
okay sure
he's doing pretty good with halo 3. yeah
i guess so i'm just i'm just you know
i'm just throwing it out there
oh foreign
and i am putting up some nasty numbers
uh
swing 993 says just stopping by to say
goodbye to michael and all his [ __ ]
thank you for following me and all of my
[ __ ] at michael p heim on twitter
and now at fanbite.com
um or next week do you or actually like
i said earlier uh i still have things
that are going to publish on gamespot
next week which is kind of weird but
it is what it is
i lose access to all my red ventures
accounts but i do not lose access to the
uh i don't know if i should say that
i don't lose access to the cms
i'm gonna [ __ ] with all your headlines
yikes
i'm gonna be like um
oh i really want to [ __ ] with tam's
elden ring uh headline
i told him to use eldon ring is the
breath of the wild of dark souls trust
me he did put it in there somewhere
didn't he he put it at the very end it
was it was the concluding paragraph but
do you know he couldn't commit to
imagine
can you imagine the engagement you will
get on social media platforms if that
was your headline dog you can get so
many hate clicks listen this business is
driven by hate clicks hey clicks hey
clicks let's [ __ ] get it
i'm just kidding i'm just [ __ ] with
y'all errol and twitch is reminding me
of a very dumb conversation you and me
had with him at pax 2019 where we talked
about if the bible was manga
oh god i remember that [ __ ] because we
it was in it was the west it was in
seattle and we were about to get drinks
and dinner and where everybody joined us
oh shout outs
this is the game guys we're winning all
right
i don't think so oh
my this is the game this is happening
just let him come to us just let him
come to us just light it up
i [ __ ] don't get it
yo matt's killing it
just let them come to us just stay here
just stay here keep jumping and keep
jumping
why are they doing this
i see them you're right there
not sneaky you're not fooling anyone
we'll find a way to lose
hey see you later matt we'll see at the
uh
we're going away party later
oh yeah yeah
uh the zoom party
if any of y'all want to link to the zoom
party
absolutely uh
were we spilling company secrets
you know what i think it is i think i'm
too raw for game spot
yeah you're right
monday night raw
i [ __ ] threw one of those um electro
shits and i hurt myself
oh
who has a sniper me this isn't this
isn't fair i don't know how he got
matched up like this yeah i feel bad now
i told you we were good this whole time
oh we're like
wow
this is game gamespot
well i don't know why you're acting
surprised man
he was he was born a gamer i've never
won a game in my life
they're just like walking in straight
lines and oh no are these bots
oh there's three of them that have 117
tags uh i just went on a running riot so
i'm just gonna stop for a bit i'm
telling you i don't think they have bots
in this game unless they added it and i
didn't know about it
i don't think these are bots i think
these are just
i think this is just people
because i think like that's the whole
thing with the infant is it's the first
halo game to have bots
why can't you remove my
guys i have a sniper please stop coming
over here
like that
stop doing that to yourself i just hear
i just see jean-luc
i want to shoot my
what is happening what are they doing
what are they doing look look what
no these are people that just got home
from work they're trying to relax and
have a good time
ah yeah
yes
come on i bet
this one's gonna this was gonna take
you did
sorry
stole that bastard
trick shots
that baby you when i used to or when uh
we streamed the battlefield five launch
day with uh rob
is that is that the battle we were doing
trick shots
what was the one where you tried to um
where rob bet
you like a million dollars that was the
one that was battlefield one that was
battlefield 5's launch uh launch it was
either the beta or a launch i was trying
to find that
and i couldn't i would stalk i couldn't
find it like i was like desperately
trying to find it but just couldn't find
it um i still i still owe rob hanley a
million bucks
no no doesn't he owe you or no no no no
you owe him no i owe him oh yo
he was the one doing the shooting oh
okay
i was like i bet you a million bucks
jordan you ain't gonna hit [ __ ] and he
sniped with a rocket launcher a plane
out of the sky
i was like wow i owe him a million bucks
oh i miss rob all right
he's still alive
everyone we've been saying r.i.p too
still alive
yeah
uh psalms says my condolences to michael
high i'm a good man that fell victim to
cancer culture
[Laughter]
damn two spices
i know
i know
uh what am i doing i'm not even paying
attention what's going on
you don't need it man this is a this is
a
wipe
oh
say that you say that in the second you
say it that's oh yeah yeah this is when
they they break out their a-game right
yeah next thing you know we're down
49-45
ah [ __ ] down
ben you have 20 kills why are you saying
no
stop me i've been trying to get this
gamer license remote for so long
[Laughter]
you just can't help you just keep gaming
and now the game is over yo let's go
21 kills i'll drink to that
we know what it's like to be on the
other side of that conflict
god damn
i'm having such a great time
i love that in the first two kills i was
able to just call it because they just
they just ran at me i was able to out
shoot two of them
it's like why do you why is your face
keep running into my fist
yeah
oh man all right let me see what's going
on the gb chat
i feel like i'm
we could stay with these people we can
stay in here and see what happens oh
absolutely if they wanted
if they want a piece they
probably i would it's good practice
unless they're like
they're they're playing us
rolling us into a false sense of
security
yeah
thomas crow shots whatever what's up
that's when they message me and they're
like hey you want to put some money down
and i'm like oh okay
halo matches
money matches yeah halo money maps you
know
oh we should have done the table we
should have should have done a fight
night
oh
with like blaze blue or some [ __ ] or
guilty gears i was going to say i got i
got you guys
although i am
i do not know how to play that game
oh my word halo 1 oh wait a second this
is it we're kicking it where's the halo
1 pistol let's go
oh my god hey that worked now we're in
battle creek
the real battle creek
it's the friends we made along the way
wait what's happening i can't hear
anything
it's hard to
hear
wait where's my weapon switching button
it's usually cue for me
why not have uh
no no you don't start you don't start
with a uh
oh what
yeah they're not gonna give you the
pistol wow
i've not played halo one in a very long
time
i couldn't pick up anything else
played um i played all the halo
campaigns last year because i thought
infinite was coming out and at the end
holiday last year yeah yeah i did the
same thing oh
uh i played yeah through um one two
three four odst and reach and reach is
still my
what's favorite favorite what's y'all's
favorite track uh
single-player campaign for halo or
campaign generally because you can play
co-op obviously i mean
i think i feel like three of the most
nostalgic for but if i was to point to
like i think i think you're right like i
think maybe like
reaches got the best campaign
okay it was definitely the one i had the
most fun when i replayed them all last
year
for me it's i think it's the most
memorable
it's also got the most co-op
you know
because it's a
four-player right well uh as well three
is also but like
plus the arbiter and three you get that
that really good stuff and you all get
to make your own spartans yeah you do
get that's pretty cool
everyone in the chat what is your uh
what is what is your favorite halo
campaign
let us know
like to hear your thoughts
i can subscribe
gosh i've got some good memories of
playing halo 1
yeah maybe maybe halo 1 would be it for
me
kilo one was like super formative
because uh it really is
i had i had cousins from the philippines
they came to him they came to america
right when the xbox
came out
and for some reason we we had an xbox we
all lived in my grandma's house there's
like 10 people living in like a house
it was like obviously like more than
capacity
like we was like violating all kinds of
fire regulations
uh but we had an xbox
and we played we [ __ ] played so much
halo on that [ __ ] and i was like wow i
didn't realize first person shooters
could be like this on consoles
um so a lot of good memories playing
halo one
co-op
and multiplayer
so yeah that was that was that was dope
i got to
got to connect with my cousins the
philippines i hope they're doing all
right i haven't seen them in a very long
time
um
i'm saying
yeah
yeah
i don't even know if they're still in in
uh the states
i should hit them up
damn some having some family revelations
let's get some master chief collection
going relive it you know
oh i should do that with my cousins
because yeah we used to play like
i have a one by halo 2 we would like
every time we would like come visit
i would like
because uh they they live down like
pennsylvania this would be like eight
hour drive i would like bring my xbox
like on the next in the car and be like
i brought halo 2 let's go
oh my god halo 2 is i so
best single player i think is reach
actually like best multiplayer
i i personally like uh reach but i think
that
the most
the best memories i've had is from two
yeah two for sure
we set up a lan party it was the first
time i set up a lan party at someone's
house and we had eight players
from through and it was the first time i
uh consumed a spider because like okay
so i took a glass oh
what
a spider a spider there was a daddy long
legs like chilling inside the glass
the first time lemonade in it yeah that
was the first time oh i don't know if
there is a second time who knows um but
there was a for yo so i poured like
lemonade in the glass and i like i was i
looked at the glass like last minute
when i was drinking it because i was
like mad thirsty i saw the spider right
before i swallowed it and i was like
wait oh it's not a spider and it was
definitely a spider i'm like
that's what's up it was a daddy long leg
so it's fine whatever the [ __ ]
did you feel it did you feel it in in
you yeah
excuse me
i didn't know how to react so i just
like i don't know i kept drinking but
like damn
[ __ ] you mark puno
for having spiders in your glasses
that's my guy where'd they all go oh
yeah yeah halo 2 halo are you ever
hiding up on rooftops from what i found
like oh no they dipped out
oh i feel bad
oops
let's go let's go find him and hang out
bro don't come hang out what's up dog
hey hey
it's [ __ ] where'd he go come back
he's running away come back
come back we'll be friends
hey
[Music]
we're genuinely trying
tried to put a truce in but
like hung out in the middle season shed
i like how blue is still winning
that's how bad we are to this game
what they are winning oh [ __ ]
what
to be fair that's why he's still
fighting
to be fair they have
four targets they can kill
we only have one so of course you know
the math works out to where like
they are probably gonna be the winner so
i'll feel bad
we have four minutes we can we can kill
this one guy a bunch
all right
or you can kill me a bunch like that
goddamn
oh my god i think that calls for a swig
of brugal tyrese says uh they say
journalists can't game making everyone
leave
such devastation was not our intention
wow okay thank rude
look
it's it's there i got it i got to do it
or which which assian is that
the
yeah yeah
do we want to do we want to switch over
to some yakuza
we were talking about yakuza maybe after
after this i want to do like one more
match and then maybe we can switch over
to some yakuza okay yeah whatever you
want okay yeah yeah um
i closed out a little bit before 5 30
right yeah that's what i was thinking
yeah it's 5 30 we have uh we have a
party to attend where we're going to
consume more yakuza content
just all the all the yakuza all the time
making everybody
experience our [ __ ]
yeah
make everyone a criminal
so it is great that we all do get to
have that like
uh here we are game of the year
discussions let's hear it from the the
crime boys about whatever rgg game came
out this year
oh my god i remember twenty tradition
i was mad about oh
yeah that was called no beef no beef no
beef on dreams
actually no [ __ ] that [ __ ] we're airing
everyone out
we couldn't get yakuza six on the top
ten i'm i'm
i'm you know what i'm saying
yakuza six judgment all robbed of even a
position
but to be fair
to be fair
yakuza like a dragon
[ __ ]
we got that
that was
that was a layup that was a lake we got
it yeah
like it just happened yeah it just
happened like the votes were there the
spirit was there everyone was like you
know what this year the crime boys
they get their due
they they they can have their day like
god damn you damn right [ __ ]
we've been out there lost judgment
we'll just bring michael in for the
discussion anyway we'll we'll round it
in
i wonder if y'all will call me in we
haven't done that with people in the
past but i'm like very adamant because
i've reviewed a bunch of games this year
already yeah michael and matt will rob
both you guys i feel like yeah i don't
want to get doing it but i feel like the
amount of people that have left this
year we almost kind of have to
maybe yeah like like
and it's it's wild that like
and maybe it's too inside baseball i'm
on top yeah yeah
yeah
but um but yeah i've i've reviewed
persona 5 strikers the replicant
uh which i think are absolutely
incredible games
yeah i agree
and uh and walker's coming out this year
and
a lot of judgments outsourcing got me
tense a5 you know what i'm saying
uh
[ __ ] um
hello infinite as you all can see from
this gameplay that you all have been
watching for the past hour and
some change i am a [ __ ] halo gamer
i'm so good at this [ __ ]
yeah
i'm literally bottom fragging
i'm playing on keyboard and mouse
and i have got like four kills and
probably 20 deaths
zombie pie uh
asking uh he's bringing back an old
topic on the forums but uh yakuza is
widely considered to be the game to
start with what's the second best and
the third best
we're the
yeah but specifically in like
i guess like play order i mean i would
feel like if if you're starting with
zero if we all can we've all unanimously
decided that zero's the one to start
with i feel like you gotta go to kiwami
at that point yeah like at that point
it's then you play in chronological
order yeah yeah
start with zero which you should uh from
then on it's chronological order if if
you're looking at multiple starting
points i think
zero is the best
but if there's a second best starting
point i would say straight up like a
dragon i agree yeah uh because it's
obvious it's a fresh start um i do think
it does rely on previous games towards
the end of it but
not
yeah yeah uh but i think there's enough
there to work with to where like you can
you can understand like okay yo we
[ __ ]
i'm still big up on kiwami 2 or kiwami
one this is a good starting point kiwami
was a good starting point
but i do think they're the first game i
do think zero is the better game and
like for me it's like oh zero was the
the one if i'm like recommending like
one game that like because like kiwami
one's really good but it's also like ah
like
it it's still very much like yakuza one
so it's like kind of dating that way
it's like if you want like
the peak of like everything yakuza has
to offer if if you if because it's like
i don't know if you're gonna play all
the rest so if you're only gonna play
the one game
i'm gonna recommend you the best one
zero yeah zero is the like zero is like
the most complete representation of what
exactly
and then i would say like a dragon is is
probably the the second best in that
ways um
it feels very much like tonally i would
say spiritual successor to zero i love
like
kasuga ichiban
is literally my favorite video game
character of all time
like
here
i think about him sometimes and i just
like i'm brought to tears thinking about
him
that is my guy i love him so much
i love him really want us playing on
this map
battle canyon oh this is the anniversary
okay wow we've played okay played every
year like all of them except for four
because we didn't turn it on
clay packs uh said thank great as a [ __ ]
boy
that is facts
and also clay packs all said to be fair
i barely remember any of the stories
from the halo games me too
um
they're fine it's just they're not
they're not memorable to me other people
like the high key [ __ ] with halo stories
which is cool
i read the books i just in middle school
yeah i read the book you read the books
i was gonna say like some people [ __ ]
with the books
and i respect that that's that's cool
oh [ __ ] i killed oh damn hello
oh we're inhaling two territory that's
why everything feels really good
yeah this is good oh i actually i really
like the way uh anniversary yeah two
anniversary films
no this is
no this is um this is reach oh no [ __ ]
you're right this is reached
oh of course that's why we
is like halo without a condom on it i
swear to god
michael you got me assassinated because
i couldn't
i couldn't handle this [ __ ] that's
that's not like a you problem
oh my god
this is why this is why game's [ __ ]
oh i'm sorry i am sorry matt
i watch you get sniped and i did not
give a [ __ ] you watched me die
he died valley oh this man
lost the lead oh [ __ ]
rip
hi the leader
the leader oh
true
cut this [ __ ] off baby
where did oh [ __ ] he cut me off
he'd see it
okay we got a competitive match here
holy crap he actually backed me oh snap
damn
all right i'm feeling it mr krabs
feeling good matt
i'm feeling it
okay okay good
ben feeling it
oh yeah you are
we're like dead ass serious
oh [ __ ] god damn i ran into like five
days at once
oh no
it's a grenade
feeling good this is a close match oh
they're sticking together
they're like hella sticking together
cubies i think that's i think that's my
problem when i play halo i always like
us we'll spread out we'll spread out and
we'll get kills separately but that's
not how it works
booyah
ah george nice is not very nice i'm not
doing i'm not i'm not doing hot i'm
though i'm the weakest link i feel oh
yeah
dude
they're uh one of their
one other teammates uh
dc'd
oh so it's a 4v3 but to be fair
um that means they have more targets to
kill
that's true
we did lose a four on one
so whoa i'll bring that up oh my god
why i gotta bring up [ __ ]
yeah this [ __ ] is invisible
where are you at boy
oh you invisible [ __ ]
thank you for the back though nice you
got
uh ben mvp dude i'm here i'm with you
i'm with you
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] gamer
oh seriously
ben is like i don't i don't know how
else to describe you dog oh
what's your middle name
uh christopher
oh man i wish it were phil i wish i
could say benjamin
benjamin phillip jenka
all right phil
jacob it's that's my whole middle name
is just phil pliskin oh that's that's
yeah one word
oh this birthday party
my top five warriors of light are
no no particular order are phil pliskin
beer champion
harry pepsi peach cobblers and
uh todd howard
and uh
there is there is a todd howard only if
i hand you copies of oblivion
um
and my fifth one is uh
lilly wolivo from the giant bomb free
company
i thought you're gonna say uh excellent
show his favorite my favorite lalabelle
chie satoneko is like
she transcends all warriors of light oh
okay
she lives in inaba the tv world and in
aortia she's everywhere
she's everything she means everything to
me
you know what i'm saying
i do i do actually you do yeah
so jean-luc and i kind of have uh same
beef
yeah
um
here's the thing all right well i've had
this conversation multiple times but
like the thing about chief is that
ga is my what like my top five favorite
video game characters of all time not
because like oh my god she's my waifu
but like i think it's because she
inspires me like she is what i want to
be
uh yeah yeah that's like
he's like my best friend who inspires me
to be better she's just [ __ ] quite
[ __ ] you know like you know i'm saying
it's good to have good inspirations yeah
she inspires you she is a good one yeah
i think she's just like the glue that
holds that game together like you you
read the you read the art book and um
uh they talk about how like chief was
like the first character that was like
designed for the game and kind of like
sort of the interesting the basis for
the direction of the rest of the
characters and i was like oh [ __ ] i
didn't know that
uh yeah and i was like i think that
[ __ ] adds up like because i i think
like there's something about chia that
just is like yeah she's like
she's she's not
like the most plot important character
but i feel like she's like the the heart
and soul
of like that game
five minutes big facts
um
man i'll play four eventually
look i i did five
uh then i played ziv for months
ben honestly like
i like no shame play it on pc turn that
[ __ ] to easy like if you don't yeah i
like the combat like just you know you
can get through it like way faster like
you're just if you're just there for the
story you can make that happen
that's true and i appreciate that to do
it on the pc one i got i kind of like
the combat oh i do too but uh yeah it's
great just that i think that is a valid
option for people who are like ah man
like i don't wanna do all that doesn't
[ __ ] it's like don't oh you have to you
can totally bypass it if you don't want
to deal with it that's uh spencer's
favorite way to play
he's like i don't bother with that that
actual like dungeon crawl and stuff just
give me my social links and my story
mm-hmm okay
uh spencer like loves his visual novels
yeah he's a big visual boy man i should
talk about visual novels with spencer
because i you really should he'd love it
i love them
did spencer know that i used to have a
podcast where we uh yeah i'm surprised i
haven't told him
it was like it's he's still a itch
uh he's still doing stuff with hitch and
he's doing stuff other places too he's a
very busy man
that's what's up
yo this uh this george guy
pretty good oh he's very good at hiding
oh i didn't save you mad i'm so sorry
i watched you die again
get back here come on man
george i swear
it's not very nice
it's true he's not
he's a broom come back george rude
all right everyone you're don't die
damn it ja luke
[Music]
keep it together
don't die don't die please don't die
whatever you do don't die
what is this
i'm gonna die oh
damn damn
i hate to see it absolutely hate to see
it
oh no clay packs oh no clay packs oh man
he addressed the elephant in the room oh
you hate to see it god damn it ah
well we actually don't know we don't
know who knows
she says she wants to become one you
know maybe there's a story arc in which
she's like you know what actually i
don't want to do that i'm going to
change and i'm going to be like
um not a cop and she becomes not a cop
and actually does good things
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
maybe there's that you can go to you can
go to fanfic.net and read my uh my story
about
ga and you know the life path she takes
and you know
she decides not to become a cop
yeah you know what i'm saying or or you
can you can watch my uh astral chain
playthrough and um
the fact that she becomes a cop but like
she becomes a uh
a cyber
uh cop from aliens later on in that game
though you know
my bad accidentally start up another
game do we do one more or do we yeah
let's do it it's halo 2 let's do it it's
also lockout which is my opinion
i was going to
there's definitely
top three halo maps okay i did get
immediately sniped so
dude i gotta snipe right behind you guys
excellent there's a double shot on them
man
i like that i like the elegant i like
the elegant design of lockdown yeah i
got the triple kill
it's a lockdown knockout i think they
change it's
one is in
because they i think the halo 3 version
is one of them i know i'm a glitch
switch
yeah there's a
i think there's a there's definitely a
three version
yeah i think there's a there's a two
hand over obviously there's two anna
versus yeah there's a two anniversary
version as well
those are got a battle rifle
the reach version
that's not how that goes i don't think
so
yeah nato is also a cop that's also true
now tells a detective
yeah you know what that's different it's
like half cop
you know
you know and if anything nato is
freaking getting into into beef with the
cops
oh yeah yeah so you know what i'm saying
like put some respect on nato's name
they're like they've because yeah they
pull up and be like yo cops y'all suck
ass of doing your job how about i do it
for you and i'm 15 years old
let me fix this really quick
or 16. i don't know how how's downtown
before 16.
hey like 1516 she's a
sophomore
or junior yes listen
i believe that i can believe that cops
getting showed up by a sophomore
that sounds that sounds like some [ __ ]
that happened in high school for me
and i'm saying
yo i missed high school so much we had
riot horses pull up to our school that
[ __ ] was lit oh my god yo you and me
went to very different schools
what happened
uh i think there was like word that like
a gang fight was gonna break out in
front of the from the school or some
[ __ ] like
a gang from another school or like from
outside our school was gonna pull up
so then like the cops
showed up with riot horses in front of
our school gates and i was like
first off i was like why the [ __ ] are
their horses second off cops still have
horses
like they have to use horses for
and it's like okay it's like riot
control i guess but
it was like hey [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] cops [ __ ] out of here eat my ass
from the front [ __ ]
we did some bat [ __ ] oh so i got a 4.0
nice
oh down
it's pretty wild though man dang
you're handing right horsepower
um in middle school
they used to do um
what is it [ __ ] what they call it
[ __ ] why you shooting me
i'm sorry
dude we keep switching colors man i know
i know i know i know i do the same
um
fights free fridays that yeah fight
fight free fridays
final fight for you fantasy
um if we went a week without a fight we
would get ice cream on friday
middle dang
actually
we had a losing streak for a couple
weeks when it started um and then we
like got a couple w's and then there was
one point when their fight broke up a
fight broke out when we were getting the
ice cream
oh no
they take away the ice cream they took
it away like what happens then that's
the last time we saw ice cream
oh [ __ ]
start getting our ass warm by the way
but you know what i'm still having yeah
[Music]
and i miss doing oh you know what um
i was gonna i wanted to drink 40s in the
parking lot with jan last night
that didn't happen
um
but if someone says yo we're drinking
40s in an empty parking lot
i don't care how old i am i'm like oh
god damn it i'm in my early 30s now
if someone says yeah we're drinking 40s
in a parking lot
i'm there if mary kish like
oh i've just said like i got i got a box
of takate and an empty parking lot i'd
be like say less
say less
oh man
i feel like mary like mary is
like one of the influential people at
twitch
literally the biggest oh yeah streaming
platform
influential person she's down to do some
hood ratchet if she said yo murder ali
2.0 let's go
it's true i'll be there
oh yeah all right
let's uh couple yakuza mini games yeah
[Music]
give me a minute to go turn that on
which yakuza did you
i got zero and i got uh like a dragon
uh
uh i suppose zero okay i'll get zero
yeah okay cool
all right i'll be back in a minute
i'll be right here
oh man
but yeah
that was some halo i actually
uh
have been playing halo a bit with some
of my other friends
yeah so it's kind of really rad to
get back into
that but uh yeah man
you can
ask for no better of a kind of a party
game a lot of ways to play with your
buddies you know
yeah they're just
really good
yeah
someone who doesn't like play a whole
lot of halo like just even just playing
this much with y'all has been
it's great i think that's just exemplary
of what halo is right so
exactly
but uh how how are you guys doing uh in
the chat i haven't gotten a chance to
look too much at what you guys have been
saying but
uh i am
glad that we got i guess like a little
bit of down time to kind of kind of
catch up
is this
how are you doing matt
how am i doing
yeah um
i'm doing great doing all right got a
lot of stuff
trying to wrap up here
last few days at gamespot but uh
you know just feeling good about things
be honest just uh heck yeah
and de niro here
hey
[Music]
which is five minutes
it's a good way to do it
what is up yeah
we could i missed donkey kong
there's a there's a donkey kong cover of
uh the anthem and it's
good as bad as you think it is
shout out to zombie pie who uh
teaches out of middle school and has to
break up fights physically
thank you for your service
keeping those kids at bay
yeah tom what's up
shots at the zombie pie
shots that's a question that kind of
thing
yeah dog yo if i was like damn if i
initially i wanted to be a teacher that
was like the number one that was like my
career trajectory yeah like early
college i was like yo i'm working to
become a teacher
um
i can imagine like now if i was a
teacher now
i'd probably throw hands with kids like
the kids that i grew up with
if
how do i put this
if i am a teacher now
and i was in the presence of kids that i
grew up with
i would probably like beef with them and
i would probably like get into fights
and i would lose my job
because
i do not know how the teachers that i i
had put up with that [ __ ] oh my [ __ ]
god yeah man
seriously we were we were
some bad
kids holy [ __ ] all right guys
ready for this
um
okay so uh
who we playing at this is this is the
like save right at the end of the game
where you can just like switch to
whoever you want and go wherever so uh
who we playing as and what many games
are we doing
karaoke karaoke are we doing majima
karaoke there we go let's do 24 hour
cinderella okay yes there it is there we
go i think the last thing we need to do
on the stream is bakamitai
that's let's get closing
yeah
and we're gonna sing incoherently
on the girls
i miss the camera do you want do you
want you could do one round of the
cabaret club yeah i don't remember how
to play it but oh [ __ ] well it's okay
we'll all remember those together well
yeah menu
this is menu remember that john okay
yeah
yeah yeah glass i think this might be
ice like yeah ice or drink
yeah something for a towel
there is a towel
there's a towel one which one whatever
one we didn't do well i think we'll see
it
okay well first off what's up with my
i just thought clay pack said kanji's
best boy hey gang kanji is best boy that
is big
okay every time
i try to explain why kanji is so
important to me to somebody else i start
crying like i end up crying
i just do
i don't know the kanji is really
damn that's my guy
uh games are good emotions are good okay
my crew's looking good i feel like
they're
all right we got the gang we got
we got kyoko
koizumi koizumi
[Music]
[Music]
when are we getting a mobile version of
this minigame
play by itself
[Music]
wait
you gotta realize that demand
such a perfect fit uh
that's right like i have them they used
[Music]
you see where their faces are when you
pick them
yeah i think right right right bottom
left yeah yeah there you go okay okay
[Music]
oh a wealthy
[Music]
the cat
[Music]
[Music]
everything is frozen
it's just xxx
[Music]
oh this was a mistake
i'm looking like a fool here
oh maybe you gotta assign someone to the
other one first
[Music]
it's so good
freaking music in this is so great
[Music]
maybe the person in the upper left is
better for them
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
oh my god john luke i hope you get fever
time i'm doing bad it's so bad my man
[Music]
zoom in okay there you go that wasn't
where you do that before the glass right
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
that was unexpected she did the
that's ice cream
ladies
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
for that ladies class
[Music]
keep it up
[Music]
time
yeah get your ass out of here we juicy
for your money
get out of here
[Music]
baby
[Music]
so good so good i know
yeah it's the the sultan bori grandma
yeah
yo grandmas yeah they they they did
pronounce it oh i didn't want it okay i
must have he must have already extended
it before brokey brokey broke boys
we don't like boys
[Music]
ducktales moon in the chat says
something i'm not gonna repeat on stream
but you are 1 000 correct
[Music]
there we go
they'll be happy with them
no they're all negative they're all
angry oh what
oh no yeah i see i see it where's the
high level meter here's the thing here's
the thing you already have out i could
just put someone there and then just
like figure time like
oh and then they'll be happy
oh yeah okay i think that's what you
want to do
[Music]
damn [ __ ] is pissed
[Music]
someone says swap out your platinum and
give it to the mega ridge
[Music]
[Music]
go
[Music]
yo michael are you going to do any
streaming on your own fan bike
[Music]
my time
i do miss uh
streaming on twitch though that [ __ ] was
a lot of fun
dorn asses michael don't be like us
[Music]
i never got this far into yakuza and
this is incomprehensible to me being
gone off that loud is not helping the
matter either hey
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
feds ain't gonna watch this you're good
all these
[Music]
all right
i got back in the rhythm of it
eventually
yeah you made some money
yeah see
27 27 million
that's pretty good
[Music]
you know what i'm saying
yeah
diana chong says just drop by to say
good luck michael oh thank you so much
thanks for dropping by i appreciate that
um
[ __ ]
damn
oh i think i'm locked out of my uh i
think i'm locked out of my emails bro
this finally happened
this is it
oh no my emails are still
oh
i'm close though
it doesn't say you've been kicked out of
the gym yet
or um slack
i'm gonna say something in general
dude that's how they're gonna find out
they'll be like oh shoot
okay where the heck is karaoke
i probably shouldn't be talking like
that in general it's over to the hold on
i need to do anything it's down
uh down to the south
and then over here oh you look for the
character the person the person symbol
down down down there
that that one yes that is the yeah
so we'll do uh we'll do 24 hours
cinderella and then bakami thai
well he doesn't do that we will have to
switch security oh yeah so we'll switch
to kiryu and then do back at me time
let's
[Music]
um
oh
[ __ ]
funny [ __ ] is like peter brown is
we will we will like
we will get something from him
and then when we start liking it he'd be
like
oh man that's just not cool like
like
i think when i told him like oh you got
me on yakuza i'm like i'm almost done
with six he's like oh i'm glad that
what a lovely fellow
which is a heck of a thing
yakuza zero i remember like
just coming rushing home from the office
writing writing the
writing muni to get home
to play yakuza and what i would end up
doing
is i would i would get [ __ ] blazed
and then i would play pool and do
karaoke and bowling for three hours and
make zero progress in the main story
because that's how it goes
uh i remember when peter got the code
for yakuza and was playing it like two
weeks early
and i stood up and i looked over at gage
and i was like yo we got yakuza early
and he's like oh is that a good game
i was like
and i literally stood there and i
watched peter play from across the
office
because i was too afraid to talk to him
oh because we're still we're still young
i was like really yeah so i just
literally like i just stood stood up at
my desk like watch across the room for
like like
i'm pretty sure about an hour all right
guys
yeah there it is
bust out your roller skates up
[Music]
do you love me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one of my faves
never gets what he deserves
my top five characters are
kazuki ichiban
tanaka
kazuma kiryu
goro majima and istola from final
fantasy 14. no hell yeah that's what
it's about
what about would actually be a spoiler
for final fantasy 14 but
the stroll is great
no no actually a meal a meal from uh
thinking about it makes me cry
goddammit i saw the emile and enjoy went
for sale
yeah you can make it easy i've never
seen him
he's making
yeah
oh
i love him i love that much i had a meal
pillow uh i pre-ordered as soon as it
went up
very excited
i love emil very much
i see the emotes in the chat let's go
we got the austin oh i miss you austin
oh i love austin so much oh
techno austin
is my favorite austin
burgle banana burger my bananas abby is
uh the best abby
oh i'll give me a sec i gotta
i've almost got all these videos handled
i've never published videos as fast as i
am now
publishing videos
oh man
cat elemental said
salutes all the best to you michael
thank you so much
thank you thank you i appreciate it damn
god damn
all right here's the here's the encore
the finale remember
is it the same spot it always is yeah
[Music]
man should be looking different dude
i love the like the yellow glow
yeah
it's like deus ex human revolution yeah
like that that 80s that 80s japan look
in this game
something else
all right y'all this is it this is our
uh finale or encore
it's an encore do you want more
[Music]
here no spawn memory
just let it go
persona three and four and yakuza
um menu sound effects
yeah
i covered the top
[Music]
go
[Applause]
i'm such a fool
i sing for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
10
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
dango
what a banger
it's the heaviest bakami tai
i feel it
it's god hits hard
damn
and that's that on that
oh man i'm so sad now oh [ __ ] anything
you want to say michael before yeah sure
um
five years of game spot it's been wild
uh i always say that i've been a game
swap fan since i was a kid i was reading
jeff's stuff brad watching video vinnie
make videos back in day jason ocampo
then the new wave with like kevin van
orde um also shots of the greg kasavan
uh also greco soft is a big influence
uh peter brown daniel dwyer mary kish
zorinte like yo there's so many people
that influenced me that made me want to
come to gamespot
and after five years i am now leaving
gamespot it is [ __ ] wild to think
about and the fact that i've been on the
bombcast
on upf a couple times i've done quick
looks like that's [ __ ] wild
that is absolutely wild to me i love
that's i cherish those memories forever
because i've been a gamespot giant bomb
fan since day one the fact that i've
been a part of it in some capacity
absolutely wild
um so yeah but i mean like this isn't
the last time i'll be around i'm still
in media uh if anything i'm gonna be
able to collaborate
freely with whoever i want in my new
position over at fan bite but if y'all
play final fantasy 14
peep
what we're gonna be doing over at
fanboy.com ben janka i wanna i'm gonna
give you so much love and props for
influencing me ben has got me into
yakuza ben got me into final fantasy 14
and ben has been a great friend since
day one matt espinelli put up with so
much my [ __ ] we worked together we
were on editorial but also matt has
influenced me in many ways and it's
always good to have a filipino brother
by your side at all times jean-luc
oh i say this all the time but like
working with jean-luc has been
absolutely amazing because
e3 2019 is when i knew jean-luc was the
one
when he's in my ear with the earpiece
saying we're going live in five
four three two one i was like oh we're
gonna kill it because i know we got the
[ __ ] unlocked jean-luc instills me with
the confidence and any time we work on a
video joan luke always just knows what
to do i can hand him i can hand him a
script my vo
here's some video footage i don't know
[ __ ] do something with it and he
makes magic
that is that is my guy also and uh yeah
i love you all so much on the stream
crime boys for life also anyone who
tuned in watch i love you all too thank
you so much for being a part of this jan
ochoa as well
you already know who it is what it is
with my boy jan ochoa i love him so much
um
that's my guy
and uh saint elasticity of me whether
you like it or not [ __ ]
that's it and also shouts out to the
the gay spot uh discord i love y'all
maria i remember when you sent me a
nando's peri-peri sauce i will never
forget that thank you so much because i
was down bad i was sad as [ __ ] and maria
sent me a care package all the way from
the uk and it included perry perry sauce
and i've never been the same since
i love y'all
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me together
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
la la
la la
[Music]
god
[Music]